if I lose some I could see that someone
stole it
so some come on means mr. Romney that's
a bottle right there that's it that's it
easy my mother when I light it I am
looking like I lost it no someone stole
it I think I'm out of it eggs down beats
do you get it
it was poppin teacher this is what black
girls I want to show you my sensors I
gotta have plants wherever I go plants a
fork a spoon
I can't doubt a little bit of silver
like everything matter like this what
plants where I'd be like roses whoo
fresh clean you don't saying like like
it gotta be clean and fresh
I'll take high burn everywhere I go I
think her rot was young I'm gonna shoot
shoot the whole neighborhood you know
matter if he was a crackhead and my
whole general curve with you what the
situation could be are you gonna play
you're coming off as for a plate she
gonna get your plate so I was like I
gotta watch her play it off a nasty
mouth and a for go to eat behind the
cracking I can't I can't put my when I
get growing I never put myself in this
situation saw when they shot to kill
plants were on the mother robbery so
this is my baby right here so this is
how I keep my smile really now just run
her this central down to place as you
can see I got a pretty smile you my name
I like my guns real successful so I
can't put in a toothpaste on my right in
my mouth I thought if I taste the wrong
to place so this is my favorite in place
I read it really listened and this is my
favorite toothpaste I have to give you
an wife's mouth I'll get sitting there
I've asked you to go get it right now
I can't go nowhere at this you are here
it's not fair everyone matter like wish
counting but now that is but long as I
can give but nothing it tastes like real
real life like a real for never know
cool did and if you don't say like the
never what I do me that I probably put
some working and Stern's up and make it
taste like potato but like I gotta have
our strong addicted to ice cream cookies
I think artists including ice cream all
day whenever I eat dinner I have to help
us train I don't know anything ever you
know it does involve I do
hey if you from here you know that like
you already know like you got her
husband own kind I like I like bananas
kitchen but when that is my favorite but
never go with anything no this is
different
I like it she's something someone be
cheap someone be expense my screen but I
don't really like to like too much fish
again for ice cream I write like you're
straight i strangle just though it can
jump with the cooking pizza digging in
China Ethan's I know they hain't been 0
if you watching right now this part look
my gosh someone open yours up right here
for you and it's not gonna just these
these this isn't our baby
like if you're familiar - nope got a
head of kool-aid rape is my favorite
color
you cannot the kool-aid you put so much
[ __ ] in it stir it up on Chrome in the
hotel room where I go I gotta have a
great kool-aid oh my god like jagged
drinks and water but I got more cooler
than me the anything so it's my baby
like I can't even leave what I create
there's no smell bad doctor with your
room your house smell bad you know you
can't eat because I can't eat you know
spanking place so I have to have a
counter with media where I go house I go
over the first thing is I can i buy the
counter and if you against it then under
you charging someone right I try to keep
this with me because I like no matter
what I smear my pride is all right now
and put it right here in the middle
everything's just Sciences you know it's
all that so it's my favorite what the
president said he said I pumped it but I
didn't hit it this neat I swear to God
so like I'm not a real smoker Sookie
don't smoke don't be like me I'm just
doing something little doing right now
just zooming right
but within being safe you take this you
take a bottle and you put the light
inside but it's a it's a fool a lot of
them should compete with it like this
like my favorite light of someone
actually made it then someone made me a
bit when I had first got the light off
and I first taught myself started
smoking I bet you five thousand you lose
his lighter before the deal with they
say everybody still like who let me get
around smoke they still like us they're
gonna steal like I said nobody will
steal my life he's having it you $5.00
so I'd be 5,000 and get my fat don't I
stay at the locker when this thing I
have is as you can see it's a charger my
favorite I'm gonna do one right then why
the hell you got to talk stupid yeah I'm
stupid
so with it being seen as you can see
it's like Tobit the E&Y her maybe I get
closer to see a good better but like
this my favorite charger I got my look
you see how I ring it look wrinkled it
looked like all over the place when I
grant but I can just easy you just want
her do you do our get my son routine
title he's my favorite one here I take
this baby everywhere I go I hate it I
actually had this charger since I hate
my iPhone like something is gonna lose I
had my two charges someone stole the
personal so when they start the person
I've been stealing people charge along
with using I like that charge would be
bad looking with so I stole a lot of
charge when they stopped my first I
stole a lot of songs
imagine usually I want you know my song
cuz I need the big
there's my baby I keep this in my
backpack no matter where I go my pocket
on the curve I'll take the charger I
don't even stop eager to go ahead these
are my drugs or her
they made by ethical I hate my own drugs
I came up with acog anger and it's
something I've designed these I'm not
man is bigger than this you know I got a
big bomb they actually sold out the
first we got did it I don't even think
that we can go different so they saw
that so pay it I couldn't get no more
being scared today's song ko got out the
snake in each magazine flavor it is you
know
you don't even go to ethical you can go
getting from ethical they ran out so
he's do another deal I get it from
Walmart you know it's local CVS or
Walgreens whatever target but it's my
favorite like if you want so extended be
smooth like man he wants to know the do
you wanna like look at all forever
you be like a real fresh one section of
socket I wouldn't be such a chocolate
with cocoa bug it on it's my favorite I
gotta have an ear where I go can't deal
whatever you need some time yes so what
so like you know we look at it looks in
the plain and simple just white water we
don't know whatever but like other
brands be like more sorry the bar be
more like little more expensive I'm like
when they put more money on me I could
cost more money really don't copy me
it's like it's really like it's not
working anything so this one hurts
pretty cheap I think maybe like sitting
or others on my feet
so they being see it I feel like I'm
gonna chop something sit mark on my face
is he happy and I put on my face my face
station what's meaning you don't think
so in my favor the last last but not
least these are my favorite shoes not
this particular color but like just like
far as like the sheen to feel the
comfort you know we need to get on stage
means I'm fine I like I grew up our
Joy's an artist I don't think the
whatever but I want like ain't having it
a lot like I already have a lot of joy
not even like a by the shoes but I
coulda seen did you know they told their
shoes on you know but I've never got I
know put a shoe on that I feel company
and I felt like myself and I found it
like kind of cross Dean's when I got
older I started liking him ever since
like especially what I do for a living
when performing you have to have a shoe
they're gonna banish you out yeah get a
jump yeah yeah a lot of clothes I got
every quarter I actually they need to
give me a deal
participant leaves like uh 85 I need a
deal from ya
right now please don't give me
[Music]